SE stay there though cuz I want to bring
in Fox News contributor and George
Washington University law professor
Jonathan Turley Jonathan um we don't
know the details but this is a bombshell
Central District of California Federal
grand jury had been convened in Los
Angeles it looks like from the early
reporting that this could be related to
criminal tax violations a lot of money
coming into Hunter through various
accounts various channels uh could
perhaps not have been accounted for
because a lot of questions would be
asked if you did account for them in
taxes what's your reaction to
this well we've been watching this
District uh because this is where the
special Council originally wanted to
bring tax charges and was effectively
prevented from doing so both the US
attorneys in California and DC admit
that they said no we're not going to
work with you on this I ultimately uh he
was given special Council status uh and
there was a great deal of pressure
because of the house and investigation
of the enormous amounts of money that
were brought in uh by Hunter Biden from
these sources and so uh we've been
expecting this obviously as a
possibility there's a couple of things
here that we are going to be have to
wait to see the likelihood is that it is
in fact criminal tax charges the
likelihood is that they felony charges
but the Department of Justice allowed
the statute of limitations to run on the
most serious allegations facing Hunter
Biden these large sums of money that
came in around
2017 uh when this matter was it was
being handled by this team including
these whistleblowers who testified
before Congress they warned the justice
department as did others of us in print
that you're allowing the statute
limitations to run I mean this was an
openly discussed issue not just in the
Department of Justice but in editorials
and they did precisely that they let the
statutes expire so the question is what
are they charging and what did they lose
the second issue that is going to
become more of a problem next week is
whether Hunter Biden uses the indictment
to invoke the Fifth Amendment to refuse
to testify uh to say well now I'm
charged with tax charges uh and I don't
want to go into a particularly a closed
session where you ask me these questions
so I offered to testify in public you
said no now I've been indicted just
before I was to appear before Congress
uh and now I'll just invoke my right to
remain silent that's a
possibility well right now we don't have
the document but someone decided to leak
the fact that this indictment was coming
down Jonathan I don't want to get into
the rank speculation game here but but
it it's not clear that Hunter knew about
the indictment before the public at
large knew about the indictment and walk
us through that because when when you're
indicted for something you're usually
given a heads up
correct you're told you're a Target and
then you're you're told an indictments
forthcoming it's not just like out of
the blue right they knew this torpedo
was in the water the question is did
they know the indictment uh was about to
be handed down as you know Laura these
leaks coming out of the Biden and Trump
investigations have been a torrent
during some periods uh it's coming much
of this seems to be coming uh from the
Department of Justice which has been
accused in the past of leaks I mean one
of the things that came out of Russia
gate was known leaks by the Department
of Justice high-ranking FBI uh officials
even James Comey uh was accused of
taking material and leaking it to the
Press after he was fired so there is
this culture the Department of Justice
to use strategic leaks now we don't know
where the leak is coming from here but
the obvious parties that would know
would be of course the Department of
Justice and then secondarily whether
they inform the defense it's not clear
why the defense would want this to leak
right but as I said this does give them
a possible out where they can say well
we've now had our hand forced you didn't
accept our offer we've now indicted a
second time uh we're just going going to
invoke his right to remain silent that
would force Congress to give him
immunity if they wanted to hear from him
which they're not gonna do because he's
he's facing charges oh it's not gonna
happen now you're you're 100% right this
in a in in a perverse way just on that
one issue it is a a very very strange
gift to Hunter Biden but obviously not
longterm I want to I want to remind
everyone what was said yes yesterday at
a press conference when Joe Biden was
asked directly about his uh family's
business dealings Hunter business
dealings watch can you explain to the
Americans uh to Americans admit this
impeachment inquiry why you interacted
with so many of your son and brothers
foreign business associates I'm not
going to comment that I did not and it's
just a bunch of Lies didn't interact
with many Associates I did not they're
lies I mean Jonathan
that's just false I mean we we have
multiple occasion I mean it's bizarre
it's we have multiple pieces of evidence
indicating that he spoke to Hunter's
business associates dozens and dozens of
time and had dinner with them and went
golfing with them well it reminds me of
Clinton's uh sort of Chess poking saying
I I did not have intimate relations with
that woman I mean basically he's saying
I did not have interactions with those
people it didn't work for for Clinton
and it's even more insulting here you
know you have a poll showing that
roughly 70% of the American people don't
believe the president they believe that
he has done something unlawful or
unethical and by the way 40% of
Democrats feel that way and so the
question is with almost half of the
democratic party you don't have a single
Democratic member who we expect will
vote for the impeachment inquiry just
the inquir inquiry to investigate these
issues not to vote on impeachment but to
look to to establish uh whether there's
grounds for impeachment they very likely
will not have a single Democrat even
though a large proportion of their of
their party uh believes that there was
something corrupt here but what the
president is is facing is a trap of his
own making he ran for office promising
assuring the American people that he had
no knowledge
of these transactions of these dealings
that has been directly contradicted
Hunter Biden himself contradicted his
father on that but you have Hunter's
close associate saying that that's
absolute nonsense that of course he knew
but can the president now admit
that clearly he doesn't think he can so
he's in this this this sort of uh Frozen
an Amber with a story that he cannot
possibly maintain I mean it's m this is
mind-blowing just very quickly Sean
given given
how
unpredictable this investigation is and
this we don't know the terms of the
indictment we don't know the counts
probably criminal tax what's what a
source is telling NBC tonight but we
don't know what else is going to be
discovered as this thing rolls on about
Joe Biden so this becomes a huge
political liability again this is a this
is a political question a liability for
this party going into 2024 it certainly
doesn't help it does because the IRS the
doj and the FBI the politics there were
protecting Hunter Joe and Jim Biden now
with the damn breaking uh we don't know
where the White House doesn't know where
this investigation is going to go and it
very well may lead to uh to Joe's
brother and Joe himself you asked if uh
Joe Biden was going to get out of
politics could this blow up his campaign
absolutely not now more than ever Joe
Biden needs and has to win because he is
the only one that's going to Pardon his
son if he is ConEd if he is convicted uh
I guarantee Donald Trump will not do
that all right Charlie Shan Jonathan
thank you all hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else